[Music]
timothy williamson welcome to how the
light gets in
thank you
so
you've had a very long illustrious
philosophical career what's the one
question that has troubled you the most
that has sort of absorbed you the most
gosh that's
that's actually
quite a difficult
question because i i've worked on
on a number of different
things and
in in a way i
there isn't just there isn't one
question that's been troubling me
all
along
you know i
i work on things where i
i feel that i have
something to say and and often i realize
that that i have something to say
because i'm involved in a discussion um
about them and i hear myself saying
something and
and i think
that sounds quite promising and then i
could do something with it so i i'm
actually not the kind of philosopher
who's
tortured
by by philosophical
questions i mean i i like playing with
with ideas and then when i think that i
i can put some things together in in a
a way that reveals something new then i
then i i do that so
as i say there isn't really you know at
some kind of point of agony that i i'm
constantly returning to
you're also a philosopher who's
reflected on the nature of philosophy
quite a bit you've written a book about
the philosophy of philosophy and you've
also written a book a more introductory
book called doing philosophy from common
curiosity to logical reasoning
in which you argue that philosophy
isn't something totally alien to us it's
there already in our lives and
trivial and important ways
can you give us some examples in which
philosophy sort of
occupies the everyday
oh
um
well i think one one that actually i
um
give in in the in the book is is a
involves a of a
captain of the french rugby team to you
know being interviewed
about um how he he thinks about tactics
i mean it's a real interview and where
when you uh think about um
tactics in rugby you have to have
clear and distinct ideas about uh what
you're doing and and you have to sort of
break a a
question down into its smallest parts
and then or you know a kind of
some kind of move and then build it up
from the smallest part apart and
that is actually
pure
um
cartesianism um i mean they're both the
reference to clear and distinct ideas
and and the the
sort of analytic method of breaking
things down into their simplest uh parts
so that's kind of
kind of everyday but
um
well and another uh example
um
would
would be um when my first child was
was conceived and well a bit after
there's a distinction that people were
talking about between
knowledge by description and knowledge
by uh acquaintance um which um
you know is made for example by bertrand
russell and it's quite important in
epistemology but it's a sort of quite
theoretical distinction but
um
but i remember there was you know there
was a time when i knew that my then
wife was pregnant and so i knew that
there was such a
thing as the the baby in inside her and
then the first time you know i i could
actually feel with my hand the baby
kicking suddenly it wasn't just that
there was this description the baby is
there but there was the the actual
acquaintance with the baby through this
process and you know and that suddenly
this as it were abstract epistemological
distinction had had some immediate
emotional significance
there was a case where i you know
it's not that i'm constantly trying to
interpret my life in philosophical terms
but that that was just a case where the
what was going on in my just life just
forced itself into those kind of
epistemological terms and his fatherhood
itself a bit like that you can't really
know it by description you can only know
it by acquaintance you can only know
what it's like to be a father as it were
well by being one i think people
actually ex
exaggerate that that in the sense that
you know i mean of course
laurie paul the american philosopher a
colleague of mine when i'm teaching at
yale um she's read a book called
transformative experience about that
sort of
um idea but you know i think
that um
you can actually you can have a general
sense of what it's of what it's like in
advance because many people have written
quite vivid descriptions of parenthood i
mean that you can get some of that from
from good novels and so on and of course
you know there can be things which are a
little bit like
parenthood
even people's relation to their pets
which i mean which are not parenthood
but but have some
qualities which give you some kind of
intimation
um of of what's going on but it does
sort of
it it often
takes you in unexpected
ways so that you know
in some ways
i don't really regret
anything at all that i've done
um
you know before my children were
conceived because you know i now have
the thought well if i'd done anything
differently i you know i wouldn't have
had
um
these children and
you know very likely i would have had
other children and you know probably
love them about as much
the fact is
these are the ones i love you know i
don't love these hypothetical children
and
and so um you know when once you love
individuals then then you you know you
you have care about them and and so all
these kind of kind of factuals about
your life
feel completely differently after you've
you've had children and
you know that's that's not something i
realized would would happen but it but
it's something you know it's not just a
completely
notional thing it's something that has
real uh emotional significance and
effects
so even though philosophy can start from
sort of common sense and concerns of
everyday life many philosophical
questions
become very abstract and and move really
quite far away from everyday concerns
you know questions about whether the
external world exists whether the world
is made of matter or
uh
moan ads if we take leibniz's view
how does philosophy go beyond common
sense how does it move away from these
questions of everyday
life to the more abstract well
i think it's actually very similar with
with natural science because natural
science also
starts with
common sense and and some kind of
natural curiosity that we
humans like
many other species of animals
have about the world that we're in and
we you know we're constantly
asking questions about it and
uh you know famously uh childre both
children go through a period when they
they're continually asking why
um
driving their parents mad but but
um and those why questions they you know
they'll ask why and you give them an
explanation and then they ask why about
that and and so that's you know already
a sort of prototype of what's going on
uh both with
uh
with philosophy and with natural science
so that you're looking you're looking
for some further
explanation
something else that
is important in
in philosophy and probably to some
extent in natural science as well is
that
um
common sense isn't
isn't fully
self-consistent uh that you know if you
follow common sense ways of thinking you
you actually quite often end up in in
contradictions and
um and then
you can't just be complacent about those
you could have a drink and just try to
forget about it but if
but you know because we're curious and
and you know maybe not everyone but
um but we have some kind of sense of
dissatisfaction with with where we are i
mean that that often
forces us uh into
uh you know going deeper and uh and you
know one famous way that problems arise
uh in that
philosophy like that is with paradoxes
so which
many many of which many of the best ones
go back to the the ancient greeks and
and maybe even further who knows but um
and those those paradoxes are are really
ways in which
fairly common sensical ways of thinking
get us into
these
intellectual tangles and and then
philosophy is as we're trying to to
think its way
out of them
so even though common sense does have as
you say these limitations and obviously
the explanations that natural sciences
scientists come up with and philosophers
come up with diverge quite widely
sometimes from from common sense in your
book you also say that common sense is a
kind of check on philosophy that somehow
any theory that is
hugely inconsistent with common sense
knowledge
is somehow
false well how do we square the two the
fact that common sense is also sometimes
misleading but it also acts as this kind
of check the thing is if it's common
sense knowledge then it's true because
knowledge implies truth and so anything
that's even slightly inconsistent with
with any kind of knowledge common sense
or otherwise uh because it's
inconsistent with something true is is
false just as a matter of uh of logic
but it but
um
we do know an awful lot of stuff ab
about the
the world not not as philosophers but
just you know but by living in and i
don't even i don't think this is
something that where we're being very
complacent because
it seems to me that even
non-human animals know quite a lot about
the world i mean they they
uh they know where things are in their
environment i mean otherwise they
couldn't get a drink or or whatever and
uh and so you know it's not surprising
that that humans you know have knowledge
of you know given that
many many species uh
have have knowledge you know and then
often
you you need some kind of
um
check on
a line of thought that you know some
kind of
reality reminder i mean you can see that
sometimes in works of philosophy i mean
again with with descartes there's
there's a bit in the meditations where
he
he follows the line of thought and he he
seems to be
proving that he is god
and then there's a moment where you just
hear the
break screeching and you know and
there's
hang on i'm not god i mean this
something must have gone wrong here and
then you know then he has to you know
pull back and and so on and
um you know and you and that can happen
in
um in philosophy and it can you know can
also happen in similar ways again in the
natural sciences i mean so for example
if you had a scientific
theory that entailed
that
um
there could not be any observers
then
that should be signal
signaling a big red light because um you
know if if there are no observers then
then how do we get to know any of this
stuff and
um and so you know even in search there
are these just kind of common sensical
checks to some i mean they're um i mean
you can't do all the science just using
those but but that they can warn you
when when you've gone down what will
ultimately be a blind alley
how do we know to distinguish though
because for example uh one of the
examples you give in your book is uh
this old argument by
mctaggart about the illusion of the
passage of time and i mean science today
theoretical physics today seems to be
moving in a similar direction you know
seem to be moving in the direction that
well time
isn't something that passes there's no
such thing you know time is kind of
static as it were and time the passage
of time is some kind of illusion it
seems like we couldn't possibly be more
certain of anything else
uh in our in our everyday life the time
obviously does pass because you know
that's how we experience the world so
how do we know
whether
you know the scientific theory has gone
wrong somewhere and or the philosophical
theory or there genuinely is something
about our everyday experience that is
illusory yes well actually
earlier today at the festival i i was at
a session on
a philosophy of physics with with a
bunch of physicists who were all and
talking about how we need to think of
time as something dynamic so i you know
i think the that's where the jury is
still out within physics about that
question but but of course i mean the
point is a more general one and
um
and so there isn't any
kind of um
magical rule that that tells us
where
something is too ridiculous to to be
true um but i think usually what goes
goes on um
is you know
that we start
thinking about well
can some
explanation be given of how we could be
mistaken
about this um
and
you know for example in the case of you
know as a theory that implies there are
no observers you know that if we thought
well how could we be you know so
observers basically are people
and you know
how could how could people be mistaken
about the being people and then you know
that's not you know if they're people
then they're not mistaken and thinking
there are people but you know in the
case of something like
time um
probably what's going on is that um that
we have
have these as it were common sense ways
of
thinking about time which they're not
going to turn out to be
just
utterly
mistaken and having have no
um relation to
reality at all because
that wouldn't explain
uh
you know these ways of thinking ab about
time which we use all the time you know
have been so uh effective it's what's
much more likely is
that
that there's some kind of
um
sort of as we're relatively crude and
perhaps
superficial way of thinking about
phenomena which also have a deeper
nature that common sense doesn't know
anything uh about and then
it's not so difficult to understand how
you know common sense you know
might have
um settled for
you know a sort of
rough and ready way of thinking about
time which was good enough for practical
purposes and so it wasn't what wasn't
completely screwed up but but
nevertheless
didn't go to some
deeper truth about about time
and is that going to be the case for
other big questions like free will or
consciousness are we given that we have
these experiences they will have to
somehow have some
uh validity to them even if again
science or philosophy tells us otherwise
well i mean if you take something like
consciousness i mean
you know from a common sense point of
view the the you know a very
straightforward correlation with
consciousness you know is that when
roughly speaking
when you're awake you're conscious and
when you're asleep you're not and i mean
that that's pretty crude but but that
that is not going to turn out to be just
a complete illusion i mean there you
know it's there's obviously something to
the distinction between uh
waking and and consciousness um
on the other hand i think in in that
example
a lot of our
difficulty
is finding
sufficiently
precise
and and kind of revealing ways of
describing what the phenomena are that
we're trying to to understand i mean
it's not that
i mean people off talk us so well we
kind of know from the inside exactly
what consciousness is and now it's a
question of how do we reconcile that
with physics or something like that
whereas it seems to me that's
that's
too complacent of a view on
on what we're getting from the inside so
you know we have these you know
simple
distinctions between you know waking and
sleep and and you know and
we're
it's true that for example we're
sometimes conscious of our own thoughts
and and things like that but
but finding even the right language to
describe the things about consciousness
that we'd like to describe i mean you
know people people often they like to
talk about you know what it's like to to
taste coffee or whatever the example uh
is and then and then
they think of the the phrase what it's
what it's like as
um
somehow already capturing the nature of
consciousness whereas you know it that's
it's a very
crude way of talking about it so you
know i think
it's again a case where
it's not going to turn out that this is
all total illusion
but it may well turn out that the most
kind of revealing and perspicuous
ways of describing what's going on are
going to be pretty different from the
ways that we that we currently
have one example of consciousness is
pain which people talk about and
you know pain research has
um
shown that
there are really surprising distinctions
which need to be made you know on the
basis of experiences that patients
report and so on about for example the
difference of between
um
you know having a pain and really
feeling the pain and so on which just
differences which you know don't we
we're not when you first hear them you
wonder what on earth are people talking
about but then actually people sometimes
report that their experiences in that
kind of way and and so
you know we we need to have some more
refined way just even of describing what
people's experiences are before we start
worrying about questions like what
relation they
they have to you know the underlying
neurophysiology
so apart from uh being continuous common
sense you see philosophy is also consid
continuous with the sciences
now someone might think philosophy in
the sciences are you know very different
they they follow radically different
methods
um they ask different kinds of questions
we want our scientific theories to be
empirically verifiable or testable or
falsifiable
whereas philosophical questions might be
seen as doing something different
being about i don't know how human
knowledge all fits together or what
makes sense more broadly why do you
think philosophy is continuous with the
natural sciences well that's actually
a matter pretty much of common
experience in in philosophy so
one example would be something like
philosophy of physics where
philosophy of physics sort of overlaps
with very very theoretical
foundational physics and you know often
um
you know that you you have
um conferences where there are both
philosophers of physics and theoretical
physicists sometimes you know the same
person can you know spend some time in a
philosophy department and sometime in
the department of physics and you know
that they're they've got lots to talk to
about each other and and
um and so you know it's kind of obvious
that the that the questions that that
they're interested in both on the
philosophy side on the physics side are
pretty much the same
questions in some cases and
you know and that it's really just a
matter of you know kind of academic
um
departmental lines that's dividing them
not the fundamental questions and you i
mean an area you know you know my own
case which is
uh like that is
um you know i'm interested in various
questions roughly speaking about the
the logic of knowledge and you know
including things like what you can know
about other people what other people
know and and so on and
um
and that can be studied
you know within philosophy by building
formal models but
you know those formal models are also
studied by people
both in
theoretical economics and and in
computer science you know and where i
mean maybe the emphasis of it is a bit
different but basically um you know this
is this is a an area it's called
epidemic logic where that you know the
people contributing contributing to it
are a mixture of
philosophers and people from other
disciplines so you know it would be kind
of
crazy in these sorts of cases to suggest
that or there's some deep difference
between the philosophy and the
non-philosophy when we're just talking
about this exactly the same questions
and you know when we took as i say we
you know because we come from different
disciplinary backgrounds are you know
our
expectations and methods may sometimes
be a bit different but but you know we
can communicate and you know results
that they prove can be of interest
to me and the results that i prove can
be of interest to them and and so on so
you know before we even get into any
kind of sort of deep analysis of what
these subjects are it's just clear from
experience that there is not this kind
of big cliff between philosophy and and
the rest of the the science one one
difference that one might point out is
the the the role that the history of
each discipline plays in say philosophy
on the one hand and science on the other
hand most scientists don't go on to
study the history of science in order to
practice science but a lot of
contemporary philosophy is based on
picking up from you know other
philosophers of the past and engaging
with the history of philosophy to
you know think about these problems to
to find out what the problems are in the
first place and sometimes even to
see different ways of thinking about uh
contemporary philosophical puzzles that
maybe have been forgotten what do you
see the role of the history of
philosophy being here in relation to
this distinction between
science and philosophy
well i think in the kind of areas of
overlap
that i was
talking about about um again you you you
don't actually find very much different
so you know in philosophy of physics uh
you know it's true
that the
um the you know the philosophers are
interest i mean they're very interested
in in their history from
roughly from einstein on but they're but
they're also you know somewhat
interested in what newton thought and
you know and in pretty much the
the same with the
with the science with the scientists um
you know and my own
training and i was trained in both
mathematics and philosophy and
um
and my
experience is
that you know thoughtful mathematicians
i mean they don't study the history of
mathematics but they actually know quite
a bit about relevant parts of the
history of mathematics and
um i mean they
you know with things like the the
definition of a continuous function i
mean the mathematicians that they're
aware of the problems in the
the history
of mathematics that led to
you know the ways that mathematicians
now have of of handling those questions
and which motivate the kind of
definitions
uh that they
they make i mean you know it's probably
the case that in
in some
branches of uh philosophy as whether the
the quite distant past is more present
you know
so in you know large
areas of moral philosophy you know
aristotle and kant are you know still
massive uh
figures it you know
but
you know that i mean that that varies
and of course you know in in a moral
philosophy you also get people who are
using ideas from formal decision theory
where again if they're interested in
the
the history at all um
they're interested in you know relative
relatively recent history i mean my
my experience
is that
very often
when there are advances in contemporary
philosophy we can kind of look back and
see oh
this
was maybe what so-and-so was getting at
but we would not have been able to to
get the id idea just by studying them so
you know an example is
uh the idea of possible worlds which is
is very very important in a lot of
contemporary logic and and metaphysics
and so on and
um
and that that idea
it's in leibniz um
but in i don't think people could have
got it
or it's as where it's use from leibniz
because in leibniz it's these possible
worlds they're ideas in the mind of god
and you know people didn't anymore want
to have god in their theories but you
know so that
what happened was in fact that rudolph
khan app um in in thinking about
how to interpret certain kinds of
languages he he
needed things
just
things at the level of language not at
the level of god which were called state
descriptions
and then he realized well actually these
state descriptions are quite like uh
leibniz's possible worlds and so you
know now
leibniz looks very far-sighted because
he was talking about possible worlds but
but i think if people had just tried to
do things by studying leibniz they
wouldn't have got anywhere they had to
be focusing on something different and
then they realized in retrospect that
there was a kind of forerunner for what
they're doing in in the past philosophy
i think it often works that way but
timothy williamson thank you very much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv